[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
free review of house of gucci this film
is directed by ridley scott and it has
an all-star cast in lady gaga adam
driver jeremy irons jared leto and al
pacino now this is a film
while i was watching it i really enjoyed
it i thought it was excellent and it is
also a film that when i left the theater
and i was walking back to my apartment
thinking about it
i liked it
less and less and that doesn't mean i
disliked it i just liked it less because
what i realized the main thing about
this film it's the main point i'm gonna
make about this film is a perfect
example where everything is done so well
in this film it's it's near perfect that
it's execution and it's amazing how
entertaining it was for such a long run
time of two hours and 38 minutes i was
engaged the whole time
but
i didn't feel anything from it it was
super cold but maybe yeah you could say
this is a story about the gucci family
right these are some cold calculated
people we meet but it still has to give
me some kind of emotional feeling
watching it especially in the end and i
didn't feel that here at all i felt like
it had strong relationships in the film
it had a really good story
but again
it's something that's just an
entertaining watch but it doesn't stay
with you i don't didn't make me think at
all um
and i yeah i never felt emotional at all
in this film i didn't feel in any sense
of form something where you could feel
sad for someone or feel this like a
powerful feeling to it or anything like
that it just felt like a well done film
that's an enjoyable ride but there's not
much else to it and that's what really
stops this film from being a classic for
me um but
the positives that you're gonna see in
this film is
lady gaga's performance is great
i wouldn't say it's worthy of an oscar
but i think it's worthy of an oscar
nomination for sure but
that's like most of this film is
everything gets the job done you know
and
it's expected al pacino jeremy irons
they just bring it here adam driver does
great but doesn't have to really do much
in this performance it's a very straight
role for him and ridley scott same thing
with his directing a lot of his camera
choices are great but again it's more a
laid-back
reserved
statement by the director on this film
and how he's shooting it which made
sense for the film so you're not really
kind of getting to see ridley scott or
adam driver really do their thing
because it's not really required here
but the standout for me is jared leto i
thought that
his character stole the show every time
he was on screen
the prosthetics on him are game changing
i mean this was one of the best makeup
jobs i have seen to date and it gets me
excited for what's to come because i
really never felt like i was watching
somebody in
makeup so that was really awesome it
felt like a different person than jared
leto and props to him his performance is
stellar the other thing about this movie
is it does cover a lot of ground it
covers a lot of time in this story about
the gucci's and
it feels sometimes rushed in its
transition to time
in this
huge story it's going for
which is bizarre in such a long run time
that it feels rushed at points there's
some certain time jumps that feel
really just like whoa hold on a second
where are we what just happened and was
that earned that's definitely a critique
i have but i think if you see this
trailer and this is your cup of tea you
like this type of genre this mood the
silliness that's also in this i think
you're gonna love this film if it's like
something you expected to like you're
gonna like it if this isn't your cup of
tea i still think you're gonna enjoy it
but like i said
it's where i'm at where i just didn't
feel anything from it and every movie i
want to feel something right that's
that's the main point of film is to get
a feeling out of you relate to people
but you know maybe it's a bias take by
me but i really just didn't feel
anything at all and i felt like
the story was so focused on being a
strong story and getting the information
right and it runs so much like a
documentary but i think it just forgot
the part of wait a minute am i feeling
anything from these big moments i'm
supposed to feel because i i just felt
cold i didn't feel anything about these
characters i can't really talk in depth
why or what certain characters i felt a
certain way about because it would be
spoilers but
that's what i'm going to say with my
spoiler free taking it i'm giving this
film an 8.5 i think it's definitely
worth a watch it's coming out in two
days
but
lower expectations and
you're really watching it to see a
well-executed film with some really
awesome acting performances but again
i'm not thinking about it anymore i'm
ready to move on it's not sticking with
me like if you watch my review for the
movie spencer that's the example it's
the opposite effect where spencer i
liked more and more as i thought about
it and how it stuck with me and hit me
emotionally so it's missing that here
for it to even be considered for some
kind of award like best picture i just
don't think it's anywhere near that
class but
let me know if you plan on seeing it let
me know if you're excited for it and let
me know when you do watch what you
thought i'd love to hear your thoughts i
read every comment try to respond as
many as i can
and you can reach out to me anywhere
tell me what you thought of any film i'd
love to hear it and please make sure
that you check out steve varley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me i share clips there i also do
celebrity interviews you're gonna see
those and if you really like what i do
here i would really appreciate if you
could sign up for a membership that will
help me do this full time one day and
you get special perks as well and i'll
see you next time